Peggy 18
hello my name is Joo Gucci ah mission
director on Assassin's Creed freedom
cried originally released as a DLC
add-on for Assassin's Creed Black Flag
freedom cry is now available as its own
standalone title for digital download
exclusively on PlayStation 3 Playstation
4 and PC I'm very proud to be showing
off this game as well as introducing you
to our new assassin at a wallet sold
into slavery as a young boy at a wallet
was forced to endure the hardships and
injustice of slavery for years this
plantation was raided by pirates at a
Walia saw an opportunity to escape the
freedom now 15 years later a diwali has
become a trained assassin who captains
his own brig the expected reading
we start the demo with Adewale and Paul
will place a new location exclusive to
freedom cry here slavery is commonplace
in the inhumane conditions are such that
half of all slaves die within a few
years it's cheaper to import new slaves
than to improve working conditions
enough to increase survival the slave
death rate here is higher than anywhere
else in the Western Hemisphere as an
ex-slave Adewale knows these Horrors and
decides to work with the locals to
liberate as many slaves as possible now
let's liberate these slaves incarcerated
in the cell open the cell will have to
take down this overseer together like
previous Assassin's Creed games I have
multiple ways to reach my target but in
this case let's go for the more
aggressive approach and it will give me
a chance to demonstrate out of Wally's
iconic weapon machete Adewale is more
physical than previous Assassin's he's
fighting for the freedom of men just
like him and the emotional response
results in his brutal combat technique
in the game you'll have the choice to
liberate any slave you see and give them
the opportunity to take part in the
resistance effort against the slave
owners
once I've located and acquired the key I
have to make my way to the cell
aside from pole planks at a while a
travels to plantations where slaves were
forced to work 12-hour days growing
sugar coffee and tobacco
Otto Wally can raid these plantations to
liberate slaves similar to liberating
the slaves from the cells from bubble
banks the player has multiple ways to
take down a spectrum however there are
consequences to your actions
determined to free these men women and
children Adewale works with the maroon
resistance helping them make progress
towards independence from their french
occupiers
here torture of slaves was routine they
were whipped earned and even buried
alive
the goal in the plantations is to kill
all the overseers to liberate the
workers you need to kill all the
overseers first because if they detect
your presence they'll see it as a revolt
and since the slave plantation
population outnumbers the overseers
10:00 to 1:00 the overseers will start
killing the slaves to end the revolt as
quickly as possible in situations such
as these when you need to take down as
many guards as possible as to use the
blunderbuss Adewale our full new weapon
it can easily kill tougher guards such
as this jailer it can take down multiple
enemies with one shot plus it has a
quicker relay
once all the overseers have been
eliminated the slaves are liberated from
the plantation when slaves are freed
they've the choice to run off to live
peaceful lives or choose to join the
Maroons
bite these Maroons are keen to help out
a while they bring peace to the island
this was just a tease of what you'll
experience playing freedom crime you can
download freedom cry today either as a
DLC add-on to Assassin's Creed Black
Flag across all consoles or as a
standalone title on PlayStation 3
Playstation 4 and PC
you